[Music]
after a lot of thinking
we have decided
that the lead in this group dance
is gonna be my other blondie kaya
[Applause]
originally we were facing the lead off
of last week's performance bella killed
it however
now that we just had this audition and
kaya did incredible and bella did not so
good we kind of have to make a change i
think giving kaia this chance to shine
in this group dance will be what kaia
needs this is on you girl all right i
know you can handle it you're a strong
dancer you're a strong performer i did
not expect to be the lead i thought it'd
definitely be like kinley again but now
having her be behind me
is weird
let's do a chorus and i need some
serious serious sass
i'm in love
[Music]
great
got everything i need and i'd rather be
chasing jason
with a monster yeah
all right
yeah i know you got that sass your mom's
got the sass you have to have it too
yes she does
buy me a thorn before he'll buy me a
rose be covered in derpy form covered in
gold he's trying me on yeah he's taking
me out say what you want but i will
never be told cause i'm in love
with a monster
[Music]
are you ready now superstar yeah all
right any last words of encouragement
mom tatum this is your time other girls
have all confidence and not the talent
you've got the talent go have fun okay
all right tatum
just like you did yesterday you were a
star up on that stage
be covered in dirt before i'm covered in
gold he's trying it on yeah he's taking
me out
say what you want but i will never be
told cause i'm in love
with the monster great job tayden i
didn't miss that
bella wasn't her best it's hard when you
see him do it perfect a lot
and then the one time it matters they
don't that's called caving under
pressure as we're getting closer to the
end
stakes are higher than ever bella messed
up some arms in the beginning
she bobbled on the freeze a big part of
the number where everybody's supposed to
stop and she wiggled
like it was like little stuff like that
and when you're competing for a score
these things matter
i think you're both gonna be stars
no matter what happens here
bella i am so sorry
we're saying goodbye to you today
she didn't mess up bad
but she messed up a lot bella's not the
strongest singer and i depend on her for
her dancing the fact that bella
messed up in the one dance that she had
this week is why i have to send her home
this is why you're gonna get through it
because you're strong you're tough and i
know you can you keep working hard okay
[Music]